Dakar,
capitale du Sénégal.
16 septembre 2008
à deux pas
du Palais de justice,
un groupe d'hommes
et de femmes préparent une action.
Il y a des avocats sénégalais
et tchadiens,
des défenseurs
des droits de l'homme,
le président d'une association
de victimes, Clément Abaïfouta
et un avocat américain,
Reed Brody.
Les visages sont fermés.
Le moment est solennel.
Ils s'apprêtent à porter plainte
contre l'ancien président tchadien
Hissène Habré,
réfugié à Dakar depuis 1990.
C'est mon frère unique.
Le seul frère qu'on avait et qui est mort
dans les prisons d'Hissène Habré.
Des années que j'attendais ce jour
de porter plainte Hissène Habré.
Pour que la justice
soit faite très rapidement.
Ces victimes réclament
que l'ancien dictateur
soit jugé ici à Dakar,
pour crime contre l'humanité.
Hissène Habré est surnommé
le Pinochet africain.
Il a dirigé le Tchad
d'une main de fer pendant huit ans.
Il est accusé d'avoir
mis en place un régime policier
avec des prisons secrètes
où la torture était systématique.
Après sa fuite,
des charniers ont été découverts.
Hissène Habré serait responsable
de la mort de plus de 40 000 Tchadiens.
Le procès Hissène Habré,
le jugement
d'un ancien dictateur en Afrique,
ce serait une première.
L'aboutissement d'une traque
qui dure depuis plus de dix ans.
Bruxelles, juillet 2008.
Nous sommes deux mois
avant le dépôt de plainte
contre Hissène Habré à Dakar.
Reed Brody est
un avocat américain.
Il est en pleine préparation
de ce coup médiatique et judiciaire.
La presse le surnomme
le chasseur de dictateurs.
Il vit à Bruxelles.
Il est le porte parole d'une organisation
de défense des droits de l'homme,
Human Rights Watch.
Bonjour.
- Bonjour !
Ça va ?
- Ça va bien, et toi ?
Ici, une quinzaine de personnes
enquêtent sur les violations
des droits de l'homme
dans le monde.
Oui, c'est très bien.
Reed Brody est devenu célèbre en 1998
en s'attaquant à un dictateur.
C'est lui,
le tombeur de Pinochet.
Il a convaincu la justice anglaise
que l'ancien président chilien
pouvait être jugé
pour crime contre l'humanité,
qu'il n'était pas protégé
par son immunité d'ancien chef d'État.
Une première.
Du coup, sur le mur de son bureau,
il a accroché une grande carte du monde
avec les photos de ses futures cibles,
ceux de tyrans,
de tortionnaires qui ont sévi
ou sévissent encore aujourd'hui.
On reconnaît le président
du Liberia, Charles Taylor,
le général français Aussaresses
ou le Libyen Kadhafi.
Pour toutes ces personnes là,
il y a des victimes.
Il y a des personnes qui luttent
pour qu'ils soient traduits en justice
et il faut que
leur voix soit portée.
Et c'est un peu notre travail,
c'est de porter leur voix,
de donner des arguments,
de faire une mobilisation politique,
de sorte que la justice
puisse faire tranquillement son travail.
Aujourd'hui, un homme
est dans sa ligne de mire.
Hissène Habré,
l'ancien président tchadien.
Ce n'est pas
le dictateur africain le plus connu.
Et pourtant, Reed Brody veut
qu'il soit jugé
au plus vite
pour crimes contre l'humanité.
Quand j'ai rencontré
pour la première fois les victimes
et qu'on m'a raconté les horreurs,
j'ai vu qu'en fait
Hissène Habré
n'a rien à envier
aux Pinochets de ce monde.
D'ailleurs, si on parle de nombre
de personnes tuées, Hissène Habré
dépasse de loin Pinochet.
Hissène Habré,
l'homme s'est fait connaître en 1974.
Il a 32 ans.
Il dirige une guérilla
dans le nord du Tchad.
Il fait un coup.
Il enlève une ethnologue française,
Françoise Claustre.
La jeune femme va être retenue
trois ans en otage
dans le désert du Tibesti.
Habré, ces hommes se battent
pour renverser un gouvernement
qu'ils jugent inféodé à l'Occident.
Le chef de guerre inquiète et fascine.
Casquette à la castro,
mitraillette à l'épaule,
il prône
la révolution en citant Mao.
C'est un intellectuel.
Il a fait
ses études en France.
Il est diplômé
de Sciences Po Paris.
On aime beaucoup
étiqueter les gens.
Je vous dirai simplement
que je suis
un révolutionnaire Tchadien.
Et l'avenir vous dira
qui je suis exactement.
Christian Millet a bien
connu Hissène Habré.
Cet ancien journaliste
de l'AFP l'a rencontré
à de nombreuses reprises au Tchad
avant qu'il ne devienne président.
Quand je lui ai demandé ce qu'il lisait,
à cette époque là,
il n'y avait que
des bouquins politiques,
des mémoires d'hommes politiques,
des mémoires de droit constitutionnel,
des mémoires d'économie
et puis des livres militants.
Il était à l'époque
fasciné par Che Guevara.
Je crois qu'il a cru
à ce moment là à la révolution.
Hissène Habré prend
le pouvoir par les armes en 1982.
Il troque son uniforme
de rebelle pour un boubou blanc.
Dans ses discours, il a toujours
des accents révolutionnaires.
Vive l'unité
pour que nous puissions
pousser
plus loin nos victoires
et lever
plus haut nos réalisations
et vaincre sur tous
les fronts de la lutte.
Dans les faits,
il instaure un régime de parti unique.
Tout mouvement d'opposition
est réprimé.
Le président veut incarner
un pouvoir fort.
Il encourage le culte
de la personnalité.
Boubou à son effigie
et défilé à sa gloire.
La paix !
Oui nous voulons la paix !
Partout et toujours,
nous avons le grand camarade
Hissène Habré.
Vive Monsieur le président !
Hissène Habré dirige le pays
avec le soutien militaire de la France.
Derrière ces images de propagande,
un régime policier,
arrestations arbitraires,
exécutions sommaires.
Les Tchadiens vivent dans la peur.
En 1990, au bout de huit ans de règne,
Habré est renversé par un coup d'État.
Le dictateur déchu
se réfugie au Sénégal.
Cela fait maintenant dix ans
que Reed Brody se bat
pour faire
juger Hissène Habré.
En 2000 déjà,
il avait déposé une plainte à Dakar
contre l'ancien président tchadien,
sans succès.
Aujourd'hui, il récidive.
Il rédige une nouvelle plainte
avec son équipe.
Son défi, prouver l'implication
de l'ancien président dans la répression.
Et pour ça, il a un atout.
Il nous emmène
au rez-de-chaussée de l'organisation.
Dans cette petite pièce
où des cartons sont entassés.
Dans son enquête,
il a eu un coup de chance extraordinaire.
Ce qu'on a dans ces cartons,
ce sont des documents de
la police politique de Hissène Habré,
la DDS,
que nous avons retrouvés
à N'Djamena par hasard.
On faisait la visite
de l'ancien bâtiment de la DDS.
Voici Reed Brody en mission au Tchad
en 2001, dix ans après la chute d'Habré.
L'avocat comprend
tout de suite l'intérêt de ces archives
abandonnées par la direction
de la documentation
et des services, la fameuse DDS. .
Ça parle
des détentions des détenus,
des ordres, des perquisitions,
des enquêtes.
Le premier document,
c'était une fiche d'information
sur un détenu.
Et puis on a commencé à voir
qu'il y avait tout,
des photos des détenus,
il y avait des listes journalières
des personnes en détention.
Et on s'est très vite rendu compte
que c'était l'Eldorado.
On avait trouvé la mine d'or
qu'on cherchait depuis des années.
Ces archives relatent les faits
et gestes de la police politique
créée par le président Habré,
arrestations, interrogatoires,
emprisonnement
avec souvent la mort
comme seule conclusion.
On a trouvé plus
de 800 certificats de décès.
Ce sont des personnes
qui sont mortes en détention.
Par exemple,
ici on lit,
en le contraignant
à révéler certaines vérités
qu'il a trouvé la mort
le 14 octobre 1984 à 8 h.
C'est clair
que la personne a été torturée,
même si on ne le dit pas.
Il y a plusieurs
documents comme ça.
C'est au cours
d'un interrogatoire musclé
que la personne est morte,
ce genre de choses.
Ces archives doivent lui servir
à montrer le rôle central
joué par le président.
Si aucun document ne dit
qu'Habré a tué ou torturé lui-même,
tous ces rapports de police
lui étaient adressés nommément.
C'est important
pour montrer qu'il était informé
de ces exactions,
qu'il était informé de la situation
dans tout le territoire
qu'il contrôlait
et qu'il avait au moins
les moyens de contrôler
ce qui se faisait
au nom de l'État.
La nouvelle plainte va donc reposer
sur ces milliers de documents
mais aussi sur
les témoignages des victimes,
les rescapés de la dictature.
N'Djamena, la capitale du Tchad
a des allures de grosse bourgade.
L'ancienne colonie française,
devenue indépendante en 1960,
est l'un des pays
les plus pauvres d'Afrique.
Dans le quartier chrétien de la ville,
nous avons retrouvé
un des témoins clés du dossier,
Clément Abaifouta.
Il était étudiant quand il a été arrêté
par la police politique.
Il était à la veille
de partir en Allemagne
pour finir ses études.
C'est dans
cette maison que j'habitais.
Et puis les agents de la DDS
sont venus nuitamment
sous une petite pluie
m'arrêter
dans cette maison.
Ils m'ont emmené là nuitamment,
jusqu'à l'arbre
que vous voyez là,
parce qu'ils avaient garé
une voiture là au fond.
Qu'ont-ils dit ?
Ils m'ont demandé
si c'est moi Clément
j'ai dit oui et ils ont dit :
nous avons des questions
à vous poser, suivez-nous.
Et nous sommes partir.
Et vous êtes revenu après
de combien de temps ?
Au bout de quatre ans.
Ces quatre années,
le jeune homme les a passées
dans une prison secrète du régime.
Il ne sait toujours pas
pourquoi il a été arrêté.
Il est sorti vivant,
mais il a vécu l'horreur.
Il tient à nous emmener
hors de la capitale.
Quand il était prisonnier,
il faisait ce trajet
tous les jours avec ses gardiens.
À quelques kilomètres de N'Djamena,
il veut nous montrer
ce qu'il appelle
la plaine des morts.
Là, c'est le début
de là où nous enterrions les victimes.
C'est sous
cet arbre que vous voyez
que j'ai enterré
le premier cadavre.
Son travail fossoyeur,
avec quatre autres prisonniers,
il devait enterrer les victimes du régime.
Nous sommes au milieu
d'un gigantesque cimetière secret.
Là tout de suite,
on va arriver à la fosse commune, là,
et à partir de la fosse commune,
jusqu'au fond là-bas
c'est vraiment des cadavres.
Chaque jour, c'est huit,
sept, dix, 20, 30, 40.
On vient
et le chef d'équipe trace.
D'abord, le geôlier Abamou Sanou
désigne, faites le trou là.
Et le chef d'équipe,
à l'aide, d'une pioche trace
et on commence à creuser.
Qu'importe la fosse profonde ou pas,
il faut faire vite et partir.
La DDS voulait cacher
l'ampleur de ses crimes.
Les corps arrivaient
de toutes les prisons de N'Djamena.
Ils étaient ensevelis ici,
souvent de nuit.
Quand à la fosse commune,
on prenait la personne,
on comptait un, deux,
trois et on balançait
la personne dans le trou.
Que voulez-vous !
Il fallait le faire auquel cas
c'était au risque de ta vie.
Si vous aviez refusé ?
Mais oh mon Dieu !
Qui étions nous ?
Parce qu'on nous taxait déjà
d'être les ennemis de l'État.
Et au moindre refus ça confirmait,
cette étiquette qu'on nous a affichait.
En quatre ans.
Le fossoyeur estime
avoir enterré ici
plus de 1000 personnes
de ses propres mains.
Et c'est grâce à son témoignage
que les premiers charniers
du régime ont été découverts.
Ces images sont inédites.
Elle date de 1991.
Quelques mois après
la chute Hissène Habré,
des fouilles sont organisées
à la plaine des Morts.
Une trentaine de squelettes
sont déterrés à l'endroit précis
où le fossoyeur
dit avoir creusé une fosse commune.
Autour d'autres fosses sont découvertes.
Chacune contient
entre un et dix cadavres,
des corps anonymes
enveloppés dans des sacs plastiques.
Faute de moyens,
aucun ne sera identifié.
Aujourd'hui,
sur la plaine des morts,
aucune stèle, aucun monument
à la mémoire des victimes.
À la place des habitations
de plus en plus nombreuses.
Ce coin de désert
se transforme en village.
Clément Abaifouta est choqué.
Une maison se construit à quelques mètres
à peine de la plus grande fosse commune.
Est-ce que vous savez qu'ici
du temps d'Hissène Habré,
c'était un cimetière ?
Oui, on est au courant
qu'il y a des gens enterrés ici.
Mais,
on est des simples ouvriers.
On fait juste notre travail.
Une autre équipe d'ouvriers
vient à notre rencontre.
Ils habitent ici ?
- Ils sont en train de dire oui.
On est en train
de travailler ici.
Chaque fois qu'on creuse le trou,
on trouve des cadavres.
Exactement.
Ici, tout est rempli
par des cadavres.
Chaque fois qu'on enlève
pour mettre le pilier,
on trouve des cadavres.
Tous les gens
qui vont faire la maison ici,
s'ils font des trous
il y a beaucoup de cadavres.
Vous les jeter ?
On ne jette pas,
on laisse, on recouvre.
On remet du sable
et on laisse comme ça.
À l'allure
où vont ces constructions,
il sera bientôt
impossible pour Clément
de retrouver
l'emplacement des fausses.
La mairie est entrain
de faire une route
sans prendre de précautions.
Ils sont entrain
de marcher sur les tombes.
Ça m'inquiète parce que là,
une fois de plus, je me dis
mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait
de ce lieu célèbre ?
Peu à peu
les traces des crimes s'effacent.
20 ans après,
il est chaque jour plus difficile
de trouver des preuves tangibles
des exactions du régime.
À N'Djamena,
un homme a tenté de comptabiliser
tous les crimes de la dictature.
Mahamat Hassan Abakar est avocat.
Au moment de la chute d'Habré,
il était magistrat.
Il a été nommé à la tête
d'une commission d'enquête
sur les crimes
de l'ancien président.
C'est lui qui a conduit
les fouilles à la plaine des morts.
Ça, c'est le livre que
nous avons écrit sur la commission.
Ce rapport est le résultat
de deux années d'enquête.
Il évoque d'autres charniers
mis à jour dans le pays.
La découverte la plus spectaculaire
s'est passée près de la capitale.
Ça, c'est la fosse commune
du village Anbin,
c'est à 20 kilomètres
à l'ouest de N'Djamena.
C'est où 150 personnes
ont été massacrées
en une nuit
par les éléments de Habré.
Voici les images de cette exhumation
filmée par la commission d'enquête.
Sous une fine couche de terre,
ils ont trouvé les restes
de prisonniers de guerre.
Ils sont morts,
exécutés par balles,
comme le prouve
cet impact dans un crâne.
Ça, c'est une partie des exhumations
que nous avons faites au hasard,
parce que nous ne pouvions pas faire
des exhumations sur l'étendue du pays,
parce que ça nous prendrait
des années et des années.
Donc, c'est des échantillons
que nous avons triés
pour servir
de preuves palpables.
Au terme de son enquête,
Mahamat Assane Abakar
donne un chiffre,
il estime à plus de 40 000 morts
le nombre des victimes du régime,
sur six millions d'habitants.
Hissène Habré avait mis en place
un système d'extermination.
Près du palais présidentiel
se trouvait la pire prison du régime.
C'est une ancienne piscine
de l'époque coloniale.
Sous la dictature,
le bassin a été rehaussé d'un mur
et recouvert d'une dalle de béton.
La piscine est devenue
une prison souterraine.
Elle se trouvait juste
à côté du bâtiment de la DDS,
la police politique.
À l'intérieur,
tout est resté comme à l'époque.
Il y a dix cellules
de neuf mètres carrés chacune.
Pas de lits, pas de toilettes,
juste un cube de béton
éclairée
par une minuscule fenêtre.
Ismaël Hashim a passé
sept mois enfermé ici.
C'est un rescapé.
Dans une petite cellule comme celle-ci,
on force
jusqu'à mettre 30 personnes.
Comment vous faisiez,
il n'y a pas de sanitaires ici ?
Ici, on oublie
tout ce qui est sanitaire,
tout ce qui est nourriture,
se laver, etc.
On oubli,
on vous enferme ici définitivement.
Dès la première semaine
de son emprisonnement,
Ismaël Hachim a vu
plusieurs prisonniers mourir devant lui.
Dans ces cellules bondées,
la chaleur était insupportable.
Vous savez, ici,
en haut comme en bas,
c'est des dalles
et sous les dalles,
il fait extrêmement chaud.
C'était au mois d'avril,
et c'était le moment de Ramadan.
Il faisait peut-être 45 degrés,
peut-être même 50 degrés,
donc, on ne pouvait plus respirer.
L'asphyxie générale.
Dans les archives de la DDS,
on a retrouvé des décomptes quotidiens
du nombre de morts
dans ces prisons.
10, 20, 30 personnes
pouvaient y décéder en une seule journée.
La chaleur, la malnutrition,
l'absence d'hygiène
provoquaient des maladies graves.
Dans les cellules, les prisonniers
étaient souvent obligés
de vivre à côté
des cadavres de leurs camarades.
On peut appeler
quelqu'un par la fenêtre,
un gardien
de la DDS pour lui dire
il y a des gens
qui sont en train de mourir.
Ils disent combien ?
Quand on dit, 3, 4
ils disent non,
vous êtes l'ennemi de Dieu,
les ennemies du pouvoir.
Vous êtes condamné à mourir,
si ça n'atteint pas 6, 7,
on ne vient pas vous chercher.
On vous laisse là ?
Oui, avec les cadavres.
Il faut dormir sur le cadavre,
parce que le corps du cadavre est frais.
On dort sur le cadavre.
Quand il y a un cadavre,
il laisse la place,
il faut respirer sur le corps,
parce qu'il est très frais.
Il faut dormir.
Vous avez fait ça ?
- Oui, moi j'ai fait ça.
Dès que les cadavres étaient retirés,
d'autres prisonniers arrivaient.
Les cellules ne désemplissent jamais.
C'est une machine
pour exterminer les gens.
C'est une machine d'extermination.
Et lorsque Hissène Habré
est chassé du pouvoir en 1990,
les grilles
des prisons secrètes s'ouvrent.
Les caméras de la télévision tchadienne
sont là,
elles filment quelques survivants.
Visages émaciés, regards vides.
Leurs corps témoignent des sévices
qu'ils ont subis durant leur détention.
Hélène Japhet est
le premier médecin à avoir soigné
les rescapés
des prisons d'Habré.
Depuis, elle a fait
plus de 20 missions au Tchad.
Aujourd'hui,
elle est à la retraite.
Mais elle vient une nouvelle fois
faire des consultations
à la demande de Human Rights Watch,
l'ONG de Reed Brody.
La présence d'un médecin
prêt à les écouter
est une chose rare pour les victimes.
Assane Issaka.
Cet homme est un commerçant
originaire du nord du pays.
Il a passé deux ans
dans les geôles d'Habré.
Il voit le Docteur Japhet
pour la première fois.
Est-ce qu'on vous a
interrogé, maltraité, battu ?
Les militaires
m'ont fait mettre à plat ventre
et m'ont piétiné le dos
et la nuque avec leurs rangers.
Ils m'ont piétiné encore et encore.
Vous étiez plusieurs dans la cellule ?
Au début,
nous étions 34 dans ma cellule.
À la fin,
nous n'étions plus que six.
Vous êtes un survivant.
Il dit que si quelqu'un
lui pose des questions
en ce qui concerne
les crimes de ces années,
ça lui fait de la peine.
La torture,
c'est la douleur,
c'est une atteinte de la dignité.
C'est une humiliation.
C'est la peur qui s'installe.
Étant donné
que je vois les jours peu de temps,
il faut que
je trouve le moyen
d'arriver
à cette espèce de nœud
qui sont
dans leur dans leur tête
et à le faire
s'exprimer par des pleurs.
Je pense
que ça les soulage un peu.
Les moyens du docteur Japhet
sont dérisoires.
Elle a peu de médicaments à donner
et son temps est compté.
Mais l'homme retrouve
le sourire après s'être confié.
Les consultations
s'enchaînent toute la journée.
Les séquelles les plus fréquentes
rhumatismes,
problèmes musculaires,
troubles de la vision.
Regardez-moi.
Le docteur Japhet est étonné
de voir encore autant de victimes
qu'elle n'avait pas soigné
lors de ses précédents voyages.
Vous avez toujours eu mal à la jambe
ou bien ça vient de temps en temps ?
Et dehors, ils sont de plus
en plus nombreux à attendre.
Ces hommes et ces femmes
ont un point commun,
ils ont tous été torturés.
Cet usage systématique de la torture
permet de poursuivre Hissène Habré
pour crimes contre l'humanité.
Et dans ce combat,
il y a un témoin capital,
cette femme.
Ginette Beyer avait 23 ans
quand elle a été arrêtée.
Elle était soupçonnée
de contacts avec les opposants.
À la DDS,
elle n'était pas dans une cellule,
elle était gardée
dans la cour du bâtiment.
Du coup, la jeune femme a vu comment
se passaient les interrogatoires.
On emmenait les hommes, on les torturait
devant moi, dans la salle.
On m'avait torturé
et ils te torturent, te laisse.
Ils sortent et reviennent,
font des va et vient la porte est ouverte.
Tous ceux qui viennent,
je le voyais comment on les torturait ?
Ils leur faisaient quoi ?
On ramassait leurs testicules,
on les tapait avec des coups de bâton,
des crosses,
il y a plusieurs façons de torturer.
Les séances de tortures étaient
un passage obligé après une arrestation.
Voici quelques exemples de sévices
dessinés par un ancien détenu.
Le but était d'arracher
des aveux à tout prix.
On leur mettait même
de l'eau avec le tuyau
et on ouvrait le robinet.
Surtout la nuit vers
1h, 2h du matin,
on n'écoutait que les cris
et les pleurs des hommes.
Toutes les nuits ?
- Oui.
Quand on t'amène nouvellement,
on te torture pendant une semaine,
deux semaines.
Si tu n'as pas la chance de mourir,
tu restes.
Et si tu meurs,
on te prend, on te balance.
Ginette Darbellay
était enceinte de quatre mois
quand elle a été arrêtée.
Pendant une semaine,
elle aussi a été torturée à l'électricité.
Ils m'ont mis
les fils électriques ici.
Là, c'est le fil électrique.
Ici, sur le sein.
Je m'évanouissais
sans m'en rendre compte.
Vous leur avez dit
que vous étiez enceinte ?
Oui, c'étais visible.
Ce n'était bien leur problème.
Ensuite, elle a été enfermée
dans une cellule avec d'autres femmes.
C'est là qu'elle a accouché
par terre, sans aucun soin.
Elle et sa fille ont survécues.
Elles ont été libérées
au bout de deux ans.
Aujourd'hui,
elle attend le procès d' Hissène Habré.
Retour à Bruxelles.
Dans les bureaux de Human Rights Watch,
les choses s'accélèrent.
Reed Brody a réuni autour de lui
une équipe de juristes de choc.
Ça, c'est des documents qui étaient
des suggestions à personne à entendre.
Alain Werner arrive de La Haye.
C'est l'un des procureurs
au procès de Charles Taylor,
l'ancien dictateur du Liberia.
À ses côtés, Béatrice Bartoli,
une avocate pénaliste française.
Elle est spécialiste dans
la rédaction des plaintes criminelles.
Ensemble, ils préparent
une audition capitale,
celle d'un certain Bandjim Bandoum.
C'est un ancien responsable de la DDS
décrit par la commission d'enquête
comme un des tortionnaires
les plus redoutés du Tchad.
Il vit maintenant à Paris et en fait,
il veut nous aider à la recherche
de la vérité sur
et sur les structures de Hissène Habré.
Comme quelqu'un
qui était dans les rouages,
son témoignage pourrait
être capital pour montrer les liens
entre Hissène Habré
et la répression.
Reed Brody compte
sur l'expérience d'Alain Werner.
Le jeune procureur a déjà interrogé
des dizaines de tortionnaires
pour bâtir l'accusation
contre Charles Taylor.
Mon idée, c'était éviter tout
ce qu'il a fait parce qu'il est pas prêt,
simplement l'approcher en lui
expliquant que nous, qu'on a juste besoin
de comprendre certaine choses
et qu'il peut nous aider.
C'est juste expliquer au maximum
les structures en oubliant
sa responsabilité ou son rôle.
Les victimes ne sont pas
les seules preuves.
C'est toujours, le même dilemme
qu'on a dans toutes ces procédures.
Parce que la plupart du temps
Habré n'étaient probablement
pas là en train de torturer lui-même.
Donc, on a besoin de gens,
les insiders c'est-à-dire
les gens qui étaient dans le rouage.
La plupart du temps,
ces gens-là sont impliqués.
Il y a toujours un jeu comme ça
à jouer avec eux.
Je vais téléphoné Bendjoum.
- Oui.
Bonjour Monsieur Bendjoum,
c'est Reed Brody.
J'espère que vous allez bien.
À l'autre bout du fil,
l'ancien agent de la DDS
est prête à collaborer.
Il accepte de rencontrer Reed Brody
et son équipe une semaine plus tard.
Paris, c'est ici
qu'habite Bandjim Bandoum.
Il est réfugié en France
depuis la chute d'Habré.
L'entretien se passe près
de l'Arc de Triomphe
dans ce cabinet d'avocats.
La mission a été dirigée par qui ?
Adoum Guelma
et Mahamat Saker Bidon.
Ils étaient deux.
Est-ce qu'il y avait une com zone ?
- Oui.
Il y avait une com zone à binthin.
- Et il y avait deux sous zones.
Depuis deux jours, l'homme est sous
le feu des questions d'Alain Werner.
Sur une carte,
le procureur note tous les emplacements
des cellules de la DDS,
des lieux,
des dates, des noms.
Il lui faut
des informations précises
pour bâtir un dossier
inattaquable devant la justice.
D'abord, il y a eu des arrestations
au niveau de N'Djamena,
ensuite, la DDS c'est dans tout
le territoire tchadien.
Bandjim Bandoum
aident aussi Reed Brody
à décrypter les documents
retrouvés dans les archives de la DDS.
Comme cette liste d'hommes
morts en prison, soi-disant de maladie.
Ils sont tous décédés par suite
des maladies dans le même mois.
Non, ce n'est pas possible,
ça c'est des tortures,
Non, ça ce n'est pas possible.
Si la torture est acceptée,
pourquoi est ce qu'il faut
maquiller un mort sur la torture
comme un décès suite à une maladie ?
Ils savent que la torture,
c'est quelque chose qui est illégal.
Le but final :
c'est de cacher ces exactions
non seulement
au vu des organisations humanitaires
mais au vu aussi de la population.
Bandjim Bandoum
leur décrit de l'intérieur
le système de répression
mis en place par Hissene Habré.
Quand on arrêtait par exemple
une personne, on le mettait en prison,
sa famille ne savait pas
s'il était arrêté ou pas.
Les détenus qui sont détenus à la DDS
n'ont jamais été présentés devant un juge.
Il crevait en prison.
Certains gens sont exécutés,
d'autres sont morts de maladies
sans que même
le moindre soin ne soit donné.
Une zigoto la nuit.
- Oui.
Et cet Insider, va plus loin.
Il raconte le mécanisme d'extermination
des ethnies qui se rebellaient
contre le pouvoir
comme les Hadjaraï en 1987.
Tout l'ethnie Hadjaraï
est dangereux, donc il faut l'éliminer.
On commençait par arrêter
les gens, on les exécutait.
Il y avait même des missions
qui se sont allées
dans la région même du Guéra
où se situe l'ethnie Hadjaraï.
Il fallait aller dans tous les postes,
même les petits villages
pour arrêter les gens,
pour les exécuter et ainsi de suite.
Uniquement parce qu'ils étaient Hadjaraï ?
- Oui.
C'est pourquoi le terme génocide
était quelque chose qui est posé.
Vraiment merci,
ça nous a aidé.
Tous ces propos,
Bandjim Bandoum est prêt
à les répéter à la barre d'un tribunal.
Mr. Bendjoum est un témoin idéal
parce qu'il a une mémoire d'éléphant.
Il ne raconte
que ce qu'il sait
et il peut expliquer
comment fonctionnait le système.
Pourquoi on faisait ceci ou cela
et quel était
le rapport hiérarchique.
Aujourd'hui, Bandjim Bandoum
vit en France incognito.
Il est gardien d'immeuble.
Personne ne connaît son passé.
S'il a décidé
de témoigner aujourd'hui,
c'est dit-il pour son fils.
Un jour au cours d'un repas,
on mangeait,
c'était un dîner le soir.
Il m'a posé cette question,
il me dit papa,
j'ai appris que tu as travaillé
avec Hissène Habré.
Ça veut dire que tu as tué les gens.
C'est vrai ?
Je lui ai dit :
tu as bien fait
de me poser cette question
parce que ça fait longtemps
que je me bâts
pour que ce procès ait lieu,
et qu'un jour me présente à la barre
pour expliquer
ce que j'ai fait et vu.
Ce jour-là,
si procès il y aura,
tu es mon fils,
tu seras à côté de moi,
parce que je suis ton père
et comme ça tu sauras
si ton père a les gens ou pas.
C'est comme ça
que j'ai pu répondre à cet enfant.
En attendant
de parler à la barre,
Bandjim Bandoum
reste vague sur ses agissements.
Son nom apparaît pourtant
dans de nombreux documents d'époque.
Il était chef de service
à la DDS en 1989.
On retrouve même sa signature
sur des certificats de décès.
Avez-vous participé
ou supervisé des interrogatoires ?
Non, jamais.
Parce que ce sont toujours
des commissions qui font ça.
Je n'ai jamais
fait partie de ça.
Oui, j'ai arrêté des gens,
mais je n'ai jamais torturer.
Au Tchad, une victime
a une autre version des faits.
Je vais
vous montrer une photo,
dites-moi
si vous connaissez cette personne.
Oui.
C'est Bandjim Bandoum
C'est le grand torsionner.
Il est aux États-Unis.
Il habite à Paris,
il dit qu'il était à la DDS
mais qu'il n'a pas fait de mal.
Oh, c'est menteur.
Il connaît
la DDS plus que sa mère.
Comment il dit
qu'il n'a rien fait ?
Comment expliquer
que pendant huit ans,
Hissène Habré a conduit
une répression aussi féroce
sans que la communauté
internationale ne réagisse ?
À l'époque,
l'homme aux boubous blancs
était reçu
à l'Élysée avec les honneurs,
comme ici en 1987
par François Mitterrand.
La France soutient
son ancienne colonie,
en particulier contre
les agressions de son voisin libyen.
En 1983, le colonel Kadhafi
lance une offensive militaire.
Il veut renverser Habré
et mettre un gouvernement
à sa solde
à une N'Djamena.
Ses troupes envahissent
et occupent le nord du Tchad.
La France réplique.
Elle envoie 3000 hommes
de l'armement lourds,
des hélicoptères
et des avions de chasse.
C'est l'opération Manta.
La France sauve Hissène Habré.
Pourquoi un tel soutien ?
Nous avons posé
la question à Roland Dumas,
le chef de la diplomatie
du président Mitterrand.
Et c'était purement politique.
C'est-à-dire que
si la France ne soutenait pas le Tchad
face à l'invasion libyenne,
on baissait les bras.
Dans l'esprit de nos spécialistes,
de nos ambassadeurs,
de nos agents, de tous ceux
qui connaissaient le problème,
si on n'arrête pas
Kadhafi à cet endroit, il continuera
et c'est toute l'Afrique francophone
qui basculera.
Parce que tous
craignaient pour leur régime.
Et voici, sur ces images
filmées à l'Elysée, Hissène Habré
entouré des principaux
représentants de la France-Afrique.
Mobutu du Zaïre,
Houphouët-Boigny
de la Côte d'Ivoire
et Bongo du Gabon.
Le président tchadien
est vu comme un rempart
face aux ambitions
du leader libyen.
Kadhafi à l'époque,
c'était le chef
du terrorisme international.
Tout le monde avait
des raisons de craindre Kadhafi
qui allait
de succès en succès.
Les choses étaient comme ça,
c'est curieux mais on pourrait
presque le résumer comme ça,
Hissene Habré était
le responsable des honnêtes gens.
Face à Kadhafi ?
- Oui.
Parce que le danger,
c'est Kadhafi.
C'est pourquoi
le président tchadien
était aussi
soutenu par Washington.
Kadhafi était la bête noire
du président Reagan.
Alors Hissène Habré
était l'homme à aider coûte que coûte.
Les États Unis sont fiers
de rejoindre la France,
le Zaïre, l'Egypte
et d'autres pays amis
pour donner
au gouvernement d'Habré
les moyens
de combattre et de gagner.
De notre côté, les États-Unis s'engagent
à apporter toute l'assistance nécessaire
à la sécurité du Tchad.
C'est ainsi que Washington soutenait
directement la police politique d'Habré.
Dans les archives
découvertes à N'Djamena,
on trouve la trace
d'un conseiller américain à la DDS,
un certain Monsieur Maurice
qui n'a jamais été identifié.
Des stages de formation
étaient même organisés
dans des bases militaires aux États-Unis.
Des stages pour les cadres
de la police politique
comme Bandjim Bandoum.
Les Français ont-ils
aussi aidé la DDS ?
Aucun document ne le prouve.
Mais avec autant
de soldats au Tchad,
pouvaient-ils ignorer
les exactions du régime ?
Les militaires français,
aussi bien ceux qui sont attachés
à l'ambassade de France
que ceux qui sont dans l'opération Manta
ne peuvent que le savoir.
Sinon, franchement, à quoi ça sert
d'avoir des officiers de renseignement ?
À quoi ça sert d'écouter,
d'être présent
dans l'état major tchadien,
de piloter des avions si on ne sait pas
ce qu'on met dedans et pour quoi faire ?
Est-ce que vous étiez
informé d'exactions,
de violations des droits de l'homme,
de massacres ?
Non, on savait très peu
qu'Hissène Habré était un chef de dur,
ça circulait comme ça.
Mais je répète,
ce n'était pas notre premier souci,
malheureusement.
Et qu'est-ce qu'on aurait fait ?
Est-ce qu'on aurait sacrifié
la politique stratégique mondiale
dont je vous parle sous le prétexte
qu'il y aurait eu des exactions ?
Aujourd'hui, oui, mais à l'époque,
ce n'était pas dominant.
Une logique politique
qui a permis à Hissène Habré
d'agir en toute impunité.
Dakar, septembre 2008.
Reed Brody arrive
dans la capitale sénégalaise.
C'est ici qu'Hissène Habré
a trouvé refuge depuis 1990.
Le chasseur de dictateur
vient déposer la plainte
qu'il prépare depuis des mois
contre l'ancien président tchadien.
À l'hôtel, il retrouve le président
de l'association des victimes.
Ça va ?
Clément Abaifouta,
le fossoyeur de la Plaine des morts.
Oui, oui, mais il le faut.
Mon frère
- Mon frère !
Un autre rescapé
des geôles d'Habré est présent.
Lui est Sénégalais, et vie à Dakar.
Ça, c'est intéressant que tu sois là.
Il vient d'avoir un enfant.
Oui, il s'appelle Reed.
Dans la foulée, réunion stratégique
dans un restaurant du bord de mer.
Reed Brody
présente le contenu de la plainte
à ses partenaires défenseurs
des droits de l'homme
et avocat tchadien et sénégalais.
Cette plainte s'appuie
sur le cas de quatorze victimes,
symbole de la répression.
Ici, les plaignants sont seulement
ceux qui ont été torturés
ou torturés à mort
dans les cellules de la DDS
et où on peut dire
qu'il y a sans aucune doute
un file qui mène
à Hissène Habré.
Pour l'instant,
ce dépôt de plainte est top secret.
Ni les avocats Habré,
ni les journalistes sénégalais
ne doivent savoir ce qui se prépare.
D'un point de vue médiatique,
on veut capter
au maximum l'attention.
On ne veut pas
que ça soit lâché goutte par goutte.
On veut
qu'à un moment donné,
tout le monde est face à un événement
où les victimes prennent l'initiative.
C'est aussi l'enjeu
de ce dépôt de plainte.
Il faut sensibiliser
les médias sénégalais.
Car à Dakar,
Hissène Habré serait protégé.
Il se serait forgé
de solides amitiés.
Il a des conseillers juridiques
au plus haut niveau, des universitaires.
Vous avez des confréries religieuses
qui le soutiennent, des marabouts.
Ce n'est pas n'importe qui.
Vous avez également
des politiques
parce qu'il a investi
dans la politique.
Hissène Habré a emmené
beaucoup d'argent ici.
Il a beaucoup investi ici.
C'est sans doute pour ça que
les précédentes tentatives de Reed Brody
pour faire juger
Habré n'ont pas réussi.
En 2001,
première plainte à Dakar échoue
car la justice sénégalaise
se déclare incompétente
a jugé un ancien chef d'État.
En 2005,
nouvelle tentative de Reed Brody.
Cette fois, il obtient de la justice belge
un mandat d'arrêt international
contre Hissene Habré.
L'ex-dictateur est arrêté,
mais le Sénégal refuse de l'extrader.
Il ressort libre
du palais de justice,
sous les applaudissements
de ses partisans.
En 2006,
l'Union africaine tranche.
Elle demande au Sénégal
d'organiser le procès de Habré à Dakar.
Mais rien ne se passe.
Aujourd'hui 16 septembre 2008,
nouvelle tentative,
pour faire bouger
la justice sénégalaise.
Les victimes et leurs avocats
vont déposer plainte au Palais de justice.
Cette plainte pour crimes
contre l'humanité
fait 150 pages
plus trois tomes d'annexes
avec des centaines
de documents à charge.
Symboliquement,
c'est une avocate tchadienne
qui la porte au procureur.
À la sortie,
les médias sont là
comme l'espérait Reed Brody.
Cette plainte contre
l'ancien dictateur fait l'événement.
Nous avons déposé plainte
à la justice,
il appartiendra à la justice
de faire son travail.
Les journalistes interrogent les victimes,
les rescapés de la dictature.
En particulier Clément Abaifouta,
le fossoyeur.
J'enterrais chaque jour
mes collègues qui mouraient,
un minimum de huit par jour.
Son récit fait sensation.
À la une au journal,
le procès de Hissène Habré au Sénégal.
Il y a pour la première fois,
des victimes
de l'ancien président tchadien
ont déposé plainte à Dakar.
Le lendemain matin,
Radio France Internationale
ouvre son journal sur la plainte
et la presse sénégalaise en parle aussi.
Tous les journaux expliquent
pourquoi les victimes se battent.
En voyant ces articles là,
en écoutant un RFI à la une.
C'est fort quoi.
C'est très satisfaisant
après tout le travail qui a été fait,
toute la coordination et tout.
C'est un matin
où on a le sourire.
Du côté du Hissène Habré,
c'est le silence total.
Rien dans la presse,
aucune réaction.
l'Ancien président tchadien,
un homme particulièrement discret.
En près de 20 ans,
aucune apparition publique,
aucune interview.
Pour tenter d'en savoir plus,
direction Ouakam,
un quartier populaire de Dakar
où Hissène Habré aurait une maison.
Nous filmons discrètement.
On fait un reportage ici
et on nous a dit que dans le quartier,
il y avait Hissène Habré,
l'ancien président tchadien.
C'est par là.
- D'accord.
Laquelle ?
Je crois que
c'est la première ou la deuxième maison.
La présence de l'ancien président
est un sujet sensible.
Ici, Habré joue profil bas.
Quand il sort, une personne,
l'escorte dans sa voiture et il part.
D'accord, il est très discret.
Il n'a pas d'affinité
avec la population.
Ici, en tout cas.
On va l'appeler.
Quand il vient à la prière,
il est ponctuel,
il est au grand
rendez-vous musulman.
Nous décidons d'aller
voir sa maison de plus près.
La voici à droite.
Difficile de distinguer
quoi que ce soit.
Mais avant de pouvoir
descendre de voiture,
un gardien nous interpelle.
On n'a pas le droit de
prendre des photos des maisons.
Ah bon ?
- Oui.
Nous devons partir,
mais nous sommes sur une autre piste.
Hissène Habré aurait une demeure
dans un quartier beaucoup plus chic,
les Almadies,
le coin le plus huppé de Dakar.
La maison de l'ancien président
est un peu à l'écart,
à l'abri des regards.
Elle est protégée
par de hauts murs.
Très vite,
nous sommes repérés.
Bonjour.
- Bonjour.
La gendarmerie national.
- D'accord.
Ici, c'est interdit.
On ne peut pas faire
l'image de la maison d'Habré ?
Non.
- On a compris.
Ces gendarmes en civil
nous le confirme,
c'est ici que
vit le dictateur déchu.
Cette demeure sur un terrain
de 3700 mètres carrés
et son seul
signe extérieur de richesse.
On sait que l'ancien président n'est pas
arrivé au Sénégal les mains vides.
En 1990,
quand il a fuit le Tchad,
Hissène Habré
est parti avec la caisse.
Il a vidé
le compte du Trésor public,
comme le prouve
ce chèque de retrait
montant 3 milliards
et demi de franc CFA,
soit plus
de 5 millions d'euros.
Depuis des semaines,
nous demandons à rencontrer Hissène Habré.
Il a toujours
refusé les interviews.
L'offensive des victimes
va-t-elle le faire changer d'avis ?
Nous appelons
l'un de ses avocats,
un Français
qui gère sa communication.
Bonjour,
journaliste pour Canal plus.
Je veux savoir si il est possible
de rencontrer Hissène Habré ?
J'ai vous dit :
il va vous rappeler,
il m'a dit
pour l'instant c'est non.
De quoi il a peur,
vous pensez ?
Je pense
qu'il n'a peur de rien.
Ça a toujours été sa position
depuis qu'il est au Sénégal.
Si son procès démarre
on va communiquer.
Le seul qui accepte
de nous rencontrer,
c'est l'avocat sénégalais d'Habré
et ce n'est pas n'importe qui.
Maître Elhadj Diouf
dirige un parti politique.
Il est député
à l'Assemblée nationale du Sénégal.
Selon lui, ceux qui poursuivent
Habré ne sont pas crédibles.
Ces gens sont malades.
Ils sont instrumentalisés par Kadhafi
et l'impérialisme occidental.
Tout le temps ils sont à Dakar,
ils sont dans des avions,
ils sont dans
les hôtels cinq étoiles.
Qui leur donne ces moyens ?
Ceux là qui se considèrent
comme des victimes
et que j'appelle
"des pseudo victimes"
qu'on utilise, qu'on manipule
pour avoir la peau et la tête de Habré.
Trop c'est trop,
c'est que le ridicule ne tue point.
C'est triste.
Quand je regarde ces gens...
- Ça ne vous inquiète pas ?
Même si on était devant n'importe
quelle cour, Habré serait acquitté.
Habré, acquitté.
Il faudrait déjà
que le Sénégal organise le procès.
Mais y a-t-il réellement
une volonté politique
du gouvernement
de juger Hissène Habré ?
L'Ancien président
est-il protégé en haut lieu ?
Nous sommes allés poser
ces questions au ministre de la Justice.
Surprise,
c'est un proche du dossier.
Madické Niang
et l'ancien avocat d'Hissène Habré.
Le voici en 2000,
alors qu'il défendait l'ex-dictateur
devant la Cour de cassation.
Aujourd'hui,
il se dit impartial.
Je ne vois pas de protection
que cela aurait pu
avoir au Sénégal.
En tout cas, ce n'est pas facile
de juger un ancien président
et c'est la première fois
qu'on devrait le faire en Afrique.
La machine est lente à se mettre en œuvre,
mais il n'y a aucune forme de protection.
Je le dis de manière
tout à fait péremptoire.
Le ministre de la Justice se dit même ravi
du dépôt de plainte des victimes
et il prend un engagement
devant notre caméra.
Le mandat qui nous a été donné
demeure valable et nous allons l'exécuter.
Le procès aura lieu une fois
que les conditions financières
seront tout à fait satisfaites.
L'argent serait le seul obstacle
à la tenue du procès.
Pour le reste, le ministre va le répéter
aux victimes et à Reed Brody.
Il met tout en œuvre
pour faire juger Hissène Habré à Dakar.
Il faut rester très vigilant.
Le Sénégal a par deux fois
trahi les victimes.
Tout le monde s'affiche
de bonne volonté d'aller de l'avant,
mais on sait
que les choses sont sont difficiles,
Hissène Habré jouit
de beaucoup de soutiens.
Cette volonté politique,
il faut le créer, il faut la renouveler.
Il faut qu'il y ait beaucoup
d'appui international et national.
Bon, je vais vous quitter.
Fin de mission
pour Reed Brody à Dakar.
On ne se voit plus.
C'est pour toi.
- Ok, merci.
La balle est maintenant
dans le camp du Sénégal.
Jamais le procès d'Hissène Habré,
n'a semblé aussi proche.
Mais deux semaines plus tard,
coup de théâtre.
Dans un journal espagnol,
Le président sénégalais
Abdoulaye Wade menace.
"Il n'y aura pas de procès Habré
si le Sénégal ne reçoit pas vite
de l'argent
de la communauté internationale."
Une déclaration étonnante
car l'Union européenne,
a déjà promis
deux millions d'euros à Dakar.
Au Tchad, à N'Djamena,
c'est la consternation.
Les victimes sont sous le choc.
Le président Wade parle même
d'expulser Hissène Habré
vers un autre pays.
Il faudrait alors recommencer
la procédure à zéro.
On n'est pas sorti
de l'auberge avec les Sénégalais.
Parce que nous,
on a pensé à tout
sauf à
une telle sortie de Wade.
Nous revenons du Sénégal
il y a deux semaines
avec un espoir
de voir le bout du tunnel.
Et tenez vous bien,
on vous sort
une pareille déclaration
qui nous remet
dans notre état de victime.
C'est impensable.
Là, je suis vraiment en colère.
Trois plaintes,
dix ans de procédures,
des centaines de témoignages
de victimes recueillis,
des milliers
de documents saisis,
tout ça pour rien.
Hissène Habré,
passe une retraite dorée
sous le soleil de Dakar.
Rien ne dit qu'il sera
un jour jugé pour ses crimes.